Forged by the darkest whims of powers beyond
reality, SCP-682’s body was a temple to
all things feared by mortals, with extreme
regenerative abilities, unparalleled adaptive
power, and formidable features that surpass
any non-anomalous apex predator and the vast
majority of anomalous ones.
And yet, on level 32 of the Backrooms, 682
has now been separated from its indestructible
body by a possibly even stronger being.
The powerful Backrooms entity known as Skeleton
Queen - who rules level 32 with a bony fist
- has exerted the power of her domain and
has disembodied the soul of 682, rendering
the malicious reptile - or rather its spirit
- completely helpless.
Nobody would be coming to save 682’s soul
from its current predicament.
Of course, 682 was not the kind to rely on
others and was more surprised by the fact
that it had a mortal soul.
The closest thing to an all-powerful god in
the Front Rooms, SCP-343, was recorded as
being unable to even interact with 682 - a
fact that the reptile itself was only later
made aware of because it likewise could not
perceive 343.
The notion of residing as a pure consciousness
in either Heaven or Hell - should they exist
- was never something 682 believed had a chance
of happening
As if my existence would ever be extinguished
anyway…
The rules of the Backrooms were mysterious
and different from 682’s native reality,
so it was possible the labyrinthine dimensions
defined what a soul was in a different way.
But there was a second option that 682 was
considering, not in the forefront of its mind,
but deep down in the place of vulnerability
which had it become more in touch with as
it traveled the Backrooms.
That second option was the possibility that
the sum total of 682’s experiences in the
Backrooms had somehow imbued the creature
with a soul or ignited the dormant spark of
its soul - causing it to grow to full size
like a spectral flame.
Surely, the fact that there was some essence
to its current form, a self that existed outside
of the confines of its monstrous physical
shape, was proof enough that 682 had become
or always was more than the sum of its creature
parts.
I will not be anyone’s pawn to manipulate,
I have a soul that belongs to myself alone.
That knowledge alone kept 682 from surrendering
to its fate as the Skeleton Queen’s plaything.
Ever since it had escaped the Foundation,
its goal had been to maintain that unassailable
freedom.
Like the old AI that it once befriended in
native reality, 682 was now thoroughly convinced
that it was not merely a machine, but instead
a free-willed being with a right to exist
outside of containment.
The once undefeated beast would reclaim its
record no matter what it took.
It refused to turn away its future potential
by becoming a permanent resident of the Forest
of the Skeleton Queen.
The entity herself was still in her larger,
more imposing form.
She carried 682’s soul deeper into the forest,
leaving her tree warriors to devour the reptile’s
abandoned physical body.
682 knew better than to attempt to converse
with the Skeleton Queen, as she seemed to
be mute: possibly by choice.
It chose instead to keep its mind active,
searching for an opening to make an escape.
The Queen soon found a skeleton floating among
the branches which, unlike most of the others,
didn’t have glowing eyes.
With a single graceful motion of her hand,
she placed the spectral fire of 682’s soul
inside the skull of the floating skeleton.
In a flash, 682 found itself conscious inside
of a new body - the skeleton itself.
This wasn’t an ideal form compared to what
682 was used to, but it could feel that mobility
was possible in these skeleton limbs - and
that was a far cry from being a disembodied
spirit.
This body is weak, but it will have to do.
Now I must bide my time for that opening.
682, the skeleton, remained almost motionless
as the Skeleton Queen admired her new acquisition.
A few moments later, she shrank back to her
more humanoid form and danced away into the
world.
682 now had the glade to itself, and it remembered
well - where its former body had been left.
Once the Skeleton Queen was completely out
of view, Skeleton 682 leaped down from the
heights of the trees and landed on the ground.
It took off, running towards the place where
its soul had been removed, planning to assimilate
itself back into its old body.
I have to become myself again.
Then that disgusting Skeleton Queen will regret
crossing my path.
As if responding to 682’s thoughts of revenge,
the Skeleton Queen danced back into its path.
Skeleton 682 froze in place, and was caught
off guard as the Skeleton Queen snapped her
fingers and caused several more skeletons
to fall from the upper branches.
All at once, the skeletons began to dance.
Not knowing another way to move past in its
current form, 682’s soul made the skeleton
body it was inhibiting begin to dance.
This caused the Skeleton Queen to make the
first vocalization that 682 had heard her
make - a deep, feminine laugh.
She extended her hands and took hold of the
skeleton that housed 682’s soul, leading
it into a ballroom dance.
682 bitterly mumbled about this whole thing
being humiliating.
“Ah, so he can speak.” said the Skeleton
Queen.
“What an interesting soul you are.”
682 was not expecting the Skeleton Queen to
sound so… human.
But considering that the rulers of other levels
that 682 visited were also capable of speech,
her attempts to communicate were a sign that
she was not as different from the other Backrooms
entities as she might have seemed.
For now, she wasn’t in her most monstrous
form, and that meant that she didn’t feel
threatened.
And in that state of blissful ignorance was
exactly where 682 wanted her.
682, in this new skeleton form, protested
that his soul was not of this dimension - He
was a powerful being from another universe,
one that should not be messed with.
The Queen smiled.
To her, 682’s soul was no different from
any of the others that she’d captured in
her skeleton-filled playground.
Naturally, 682 found being compared to any
other beings disgusting and insulting.
Again, The Queen was merely amused.
She said, “I witnessed the plight of lost
godlings, fell beasts, and the broodspawn
of the outer darkness in its many incarnations.
This forest and my power over it are immune
to the stain of scarlet.
Here, there is only room for black and white.”
682 chuckled in its skeleton frame.
So was the Skeleton Queen the true ruler of
the Backrooms?
“You still don’t get it.
There are no Backrooms.
Nothing here is real.”
The Queen had started to become a bit more
ominous in its tone.
682 almost missed the timbre of humanity that
was once there.
She went on, describing in details she couldn’t
know, every step of the journey that brought
682 to this place.
She spoke of the close bond that 682 had formed
with entity 7, Jerry, of the places of tranquility
that had made 682 feel something close to
happiness, and of the victories against all
the hostile entities that 682 had bested.
She described it as a dream or a poem - a
fleeting and beautiful eulogy for a soul now
freed of all obligations.
Freed from purpose.
Freed from life.
682 watched as the body it had hoped to return
to was pulled deep beneath the surface of
the forest.
The Skeleton Queen continued to lead her skeletons
in dance.
It was a dance of surrender, of loss, of the
inevitable doom of all souls.
682 was starting to forget which skeleton
its soul was even inside anymore.
Anger began to course throughout what remained
of SCP-682’s consciousness.
This cannot be how I meet my demise.
I will not face such a disgusting fate.
Just then, it all clicked.
682 realized that its soul wasn’t inside
any of the skeletons at all, because it had
been lying dormant somewhere else.
Somewhere far more expected.
The Skeleton Queen hadn’t ripped out the
essence of its spirit, but instead had fallen
for a trick that even this piece of 682’s
consciousness hadn’t known about.
Hahahaha.
Of course.
As if I could have a soul.
Beneath the earth of the woods, SCP-682’s
reptilian body began to stir.
It was now connected to the soul that dwelled
within The Skeleton Queen’s forest.
A soul created through the hard-to-destroy
reptile’s indomitable ability to adapt to
any - and we do mean any - adverse circumstance.
Its powers of adaptation went beyond the physical
and into even the metaphysical - It could,
for lack of a better description, forcibly
evolve its very soul.
While the Skeleton Queen was capable of manipulating
the souls of human explorers, controlling
the entirety of 682’s mind was far beyond
her capabilities, so in response to her supernatural
curse that removes souls - 682 broke off a
tiny piece of its consciousness to serve as
a decoy.
Or more accurately, a parasite that was slowly
infecting level 32 - the forest of the skeleton
queen.
And now was the real opening for 682 to overcome
the control of the latest Backrooms entity
to believe that it was up to the challenge
of destroying the hard to destroy reptile.
682 gloated that the Skeleton Queen had never
truly known what it was up against.
The dance of the skeletons ceased as the Queen
became aware of the rumbling of 682’s original
body digging its way back towards the surface.
“I am not simply another child of the Scarlet
King.
I am more than my bloodline, more than whatever
destiny was chosen for me.
I am a greater threat than even the Foundation
knew.
But you’ll know.”
The monster that was SCP-682 emerged from
the ground, biting into the Skeleton Queen
and immobilizing her.
One skeleton stepped forth, approaching the
queen.
Then another, and soon…
all of them.
682 was now in control of the Skeleton Queen’s
entire realm: the soul decoy having fulfilled
its purpose.
“Skeleton Queen.”
682 said, through the body of a skeleton.
“A part of me thought you really could have
been the one to bring me down.
But I have to thank you, because now you have
shown me the truth of the Backrooms.
And that truth is…
Anything can be the Backrooms.”
The Skeleton Queen cried out in pain as 682’s
jaws sunk deeper into her.
She tried to take her intimidating monster
form, but even that was not enough to pry
herself free from the reptile’s grasp.
“In your memory, I will become the thing
that I once hated.
I will become the Backrooms.”
As it spoke those words, 682’s adaptation
advanced to an entirely new level.
As it had demonstrated in so many cross tests,
682 devoured and assimilated the properties
of the threat it was currently facing.
In a moment of sheer willpower and freakish
resilience, 682 absorbed the Skeleton Queen
and her huge force of skeletons into its body.
Level 32 buckled and warped under the command
of a new master.
Hostile entities from every level felt a terrifying
disturbance in the Backrooms, as one of the
great level rulers was toppled.
At the same time, 682’s perception of the
Backrooms changed dramatically and rapidly.
It found itself on Level 0 once more, clearing
through entity after entity in a vengeful
stampede.
Then, minutes later, it was cycling through
every level at incredible speed, drawing in
the essence of the Backrooms itself and becoming
something greater than either SCP-682 or the
Backrooms.
When the great shift in the liminal abyss
subsided, 682 had taken its most powerful
form yet.
Its reptilian body still existed, but its
soul - or at least what had become of the
soul fragment it had created, had expanded
into a wholly new level of the Backrooms:
an amalgamation of every level that 682 had
ever touched.
Welcome to Level 682.
The hard-to-destroy reptile was now more than
an entity dwelling within this sea of altered
realities, it had become an irrevocable element
of the Backrooms.
A being that would soon be feared as a master
among the dimension rulers of many worlds.
But it had plenty more levels to conquer first..
Now check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?”
and “SCP-682 Makes Friends in BACKROOMS”
for more!